e
well good morning
everybody thank you for being here I'd
like to um convene this interim study
subcommittee meeting of the children and
family law uh committee to um take a
look at House Bill 1269 relative to the
use of childood restraints in schools
and I'm uh representative Peter patrino
from Milford I serve as the clerk on
children and family law and if the other
members uh would uh introduce
themselves good morning I'm
representative long from
Manchester and good morning I'm
representative Deb D Simone from
Atkinson good morning I'm representative
Jody Nelson from
Derry Heather Raymond from NASA
I am CC from
barington and I'm Candace Gibbons from
Manchester and thank you all for being
here I do appreciate that
so the purpose of our our meeting is to
take a look at House Bill uh 1269 and
when it came before children and family
law I uh had some concerns with u the
bill as proposed and initially my
inclination was going to be to recommend
itl but hearing the testimony of uh many
parents uh it was heartfelt and I felt
it would be very insensitive if we just
dismissed this legislation and didn't
discuss it any further considering the
testimony of the parents so that's why I
requested uh that we take a look at it
as an inum study so and that's where we
are
today um
you take a look at the bill as proposed
uh amending RSA 126
u5b it talks about as soon as practical
pursuant to RSA
18968 Roman num 5D each use of seclusion
shall be visually and auditorally
recorded if such method of recording is
included in the students individualized
educational program or accommodating
plan
another part that was added to the
statute in this bill was pursuant to RSA
18968 Roman numeral 5D each use of
restraint shall be visually and
auditorally recorded if such method of
recording is included in the students
individual educational program or
accommodation plan and my concern with
that language is that students with IEPs
are mainstreamed and from my perspective
this would mean that every class room
and every school would have to be
equipped with um with
surveillances and so that was my uh
initial concern and my inclination again
to uh itl it but before the committee
begins discussing uh this in detail I
see we have some individuals who are
here and this is not a public testimony
we've heard testimony but I do welcome
any of you to come forward if you want
to add any insight or just any
perspectives you may may have before we
begin but again this is not public
testimony because we've already heard
the testimony we've looked at this bill
and now we're going to take a look at
its merits and maybe make some
recommendations going forward so with
that you are welcome to come forward if
you're so inclined if not we will um we
will
commence maren
definitely just um turn on the
microphone and introduce yourself and
from oh is it on
that's odd because it's red instead of
green usually I'm used to it being green
um so thank you I'm Marin Tracy I'm from
marac New Hampshire and um I was the one
who kind of grabbed the legislators
together to kind of discuss this because
of the number of calls that I was
receiving um from families who you all
um saw that was just a small portion of
them and honestly I was just cleaning my
house one day and I'm like how can I try
to help stop this or less in this and
that the cameras came into my into my
mind to address just quickly the
concern uh in regards to in the
classroom I um in my 25 plus years of
education have not really seen a child
restrained in a regular Ed classroom it
doesn't typically happen in other in
front of other people and that's why and
I I you know I didn't make this language
I wasn't that um excited about this but
you know some attorney put it together
and put it through all I'm looking for
is um somebody else to be able to have a
voice when a child is either put in a
restraint or seclusion or comes home
with an injury and they can't
communicate that's really what I'm
looking for um so is it a person is it a
camera is it a camera on a on an adult
I don't know but um one of the
um you know one of the legislations that
passed last year was covered bridges
would have cameras because people are
putting graffiti on them in the middle
of the night when nobody's there and
they want to protect them and I'm like
how do we protect our kids and I am
willing um to work one day a week on
Research or anything that you would like
if um you come up with an idea that
would really help to give children a
voice when they have been hurt
restrained or secluded that's that's
really all I'm asking for there are two
sides to every story um when I first
started an education when I was working
at UNH I used to visit so many different
schools so many different places and
people I guess I was unassuming people
would would not change their behavior in
front of me and I have seen kids thrown
against the wall I have seen kids thrown
onto the ground um I I've seen it and it
mostly happens in the Middle School it's
not we're not really talking about high
school um it's it's usually around um 8
to 10 uh 7 to 11 is the average age of
when this happens so that's what I would
like I would be willing to give really
any research anything that you would
like any questions um one day week if um
that's something that the committee
would like that's all thank you would
you be open 20 any questions yeah okay
all right before um I entertain the
other reps uh one quick question if I
recall you brought to my attention uh
Statute in in the state of Maine that
you thought was something that we could
model okay all right that's important to
know because I did take a look at the
statute and I'm looking at uh in their
RSA specifically um line item six that
talks about technical assistance and I
think this may be where what you were
referring to so just correct me if
that's the case it says the department
shall provide technical assistance to
cover entities by developing
implementing and providing technical
assistance to support evidence-based
programs that reduce the likelihood of
physical restraint and support students
in reducing behavior that can result in
physical restraint such as
developmentally appropriate positive
behavior interventions functional
Behavior interventions mental health
support restorative justice programs
trauma informed care and crisis in uh
deescalation interventions was that the
part of the statute that you were making
reference to um yes and I do believe
that we do have some of that in our both
state and federal laws um and I actually
was one of the first um was first and
only PBIS coordinators here in the State
I have worked with many schools on
exactly implementing and teaching fb's
PBIS throughout school districts um the
hardest thing is for what what I see is
that um the people who are where this is
happening are the least trained and they
don't want to tell anybody that they
made a mistake and um therefore it
escalates and we really need to support
those people it one like one of the
concerns I just saw was London Derry is
looking for
um par Educators and they're paying
something like don't quote me but say
1725 for a par educator who assists a
classroom in like
1795 to work with a behavior kid really
that's like it that's just saying that
it's it's not that much difference and
it is it it it is and you really it's
not fair to the adults or the young
people um if you're not trained properly
and then you feel I'm going to tell you
they feel embarrassed that they got this
to happen and then they blame the kid
because that that's what happens so
that's what I see well thank you and I
was taking a look at our Statute in
section 126
u1a it talks about limitations of child
restraint practices and it seems the way
I read it that there's some similarity
in that main statute it says the
Department of Education and the
Department of Labor shall work
cooperatively to develop consistent
definitions and applic of this chapter
in order to inform School administrators
and employees across the state of best
practices regarding restraint in schools
the Department of Education May utilize
Grant funds that are available through
the Department's office of students
Wellness for trauma responsive training
Consulting on de-escalating violent
situations and proper use of restraints
so I'm seeing very similar language in
New Hampshire Statute in my view seems
to be somewhat consistent with what they
have in Maine so Y what are your
thoughts in that regard um um I so my
thoughts in that regard is that I think
the state in my in my view the state was
doing a really good job preo after covid
anxiety went up in everybody adults and
young people and I think that led to
more behaviors as well as a lot of
people left the field so I I think
that's a lot one of the things that I
did research and I believe it was
Mississippi um um is not putting
something like this underneath um child
restraints but instead under child
safety including and it was included in
a bill in regards to having like locked
front doors and and all of that stuff so
it was and then it went into you know
cameras in the hallway cameras in the
lunchroom because we have cameras
everywhere we really do even in the
schools so um looking at it as far as um
having it maybe not in RSA 126 u in
restraints and seclusion cuz it's not
just around restraints and seclusion um
it it's kind of you know we we're we're
putting kids who are vulnerable in a PL
in a in a room away from other people
and things happen that's I guess the
bottom line okay thank you
representative Gibbons I saw you hand up
do you have a question oh I did but it
got answered thank you okay any anyone
else representative
long yeah thank you Mr chairman um so so
it looks like two efforts on here one
is
um one is regarding the restraint itself
uh the less the better uh then the other
one is regarding the
notification um now the uh 1269 was more
on the
notification
um and you know and the issues I had was
the uh um uh prior to using seclusion or
restraint the parent had to be notified
that's not always I I don't I don't
think I don't think that's reasonable at
all I don't think that I I didn't come
up with that I don't think that's a
reasonable reasonable part no okay so so
as far as I I mean I agree that a parent
should be notified for all kids even
even even if they can't um Express what
happened to them um I I think ought to
know what right child who's secluded or
restrained the parent ought to be told
so I guess what we're looking for is who
would be responsible for that
right and I I believe there is already
information and Karen Rosenberg is here
she could probably let you know I
believe we're already supposed to be
doing that is notifying the parent right
away um so and let me tell you about
functional Behavior assessment and
that's one of the things I taught
functional Behavior assessment is who
what when where how why and you want to
grab that data and be able to look at it
and prevent it and um and and I've
prevented it like like I've done this
work that's why I can say that it works
and we're not collecting that
information who what when where how why
and instead if you read and I would I
would love for you to read any incident
reports it's very vague this is what the
child did no like it's almost like they
were in a room by themselves and that
there was nobody else there to um
intervening and typically an adult is is
looking what the trigger is in so I'll
give you my first experience with
restraint I was teaching preschool um
and a um a a there was a student who had
autism this was way way back so autism
wasn't a like as known as it is now and
the student did not want to put their
hand in paint and this teacher came over
and put their hand in the paint and the
and the student like freaked out and
then was put on the ground and held down
and it was like that was not worth you
know having this huge problem going on
right so what we want to know is we want
to prevent that from happening again so
so and I could give you a million
different examples of um of how these
things get triggered but it's
understanding
and preventing it is the biggest thing
yes oh sorry representative Raymond uh
thank you very briefly have you seen the
new reporting form that came out I know
that I'm in naswa and we adopted it um
in March and it is um 15 pages long and
it specifically has you have to list
every staff member that was
involved um you have to say the all of
the events preceding it you have to EXP
explain any interventions that happened
before the event um and then there's
there's a narrative and there's a bunch
of check boxes to trigger people to
think about what things they should be
using for next time um you have to
provide a narrative justifying the the
reason that restraint or seclusion or a
hold was
used um you have to document any um
injuries that occurred before or after
the seclusion whether the was injured
during this inclusion whether the staff
member was injured um it just it goes on
and on um and so I'm wondering if and
then in naswa we require um notification
immediately by fo which is consistent
but we also require the parent to have a
copy of this form and that the form be
re reviewed by the superintendent and
the parent to get a report from the
superintendent saying he's reviewed it
he's talked to all the staff and this is
what his investigation found so I guess
my question is um given that most of
this detail is new it wasn't state law
before and a lot of places there were a
lot of inconsistencies across the
state do does this cover some of those
circumstances where it provides some
evidence for what's going on I would say
yes it does um in regards to restraint
and seclusion but I just want to remind
you that some of the people that
testified their kid was not restrained
or secluded but came home with injuries
so that's that's another thing but um I
think that this is the difference I have
I have seen that but I have not seen it
filled out and I think that's that's the
key there was good good um paperwork to
fill out before that that I have seen
but it it it's how it's filled out and
and people are not always um and usually
again we're going back to direct direct
support professionals they're not always
trained in my experience as a teacher as
as an educator things would come down
from the state they would get funneled
you know through the specialed
administrator maybe a coordinator it
hardly ever gets down to the um to the
to the par professionals and they don't
have a lot of information and the the
main thing that they go back on for
evidence-based practices is CPI right
and that's like the same thing over and
over and over
again right so I mean it sounds like
this is a I don't know I guess for me
we're on day four five of school um so I
you know I'd like to see people using it
and I know in Nashville we've got Dr
Green coming down specifically to train
our parent Educators so hopefully more
districts can do that kind of stuff
that's wonderful that's wonderful
representative Nelson thank you Mr
chair hello good morning morning um so
I'm seeing this um you know if we are
able to craft a bill I'm seeing that
this would be sort of like a two-prong
um reasoning one for the protection of
the children and two for a training
purposes so you can review the incident
and um you know U make sure that um
people are trained properly in order to
handle it and in the future maybe
uh maybe not uh have it get to a point
of escalation is that what you're what
you would like to I think that's
beautiful yes I think that's beautiful I
um my my again my experience so I was an
educator um my daughter was on spring
break or whatever break and came and
substituted in a school that I was
working in and they put her with the
hardest kid who is
nonverbal luckily she has a sister who
has prayer willly syndrome and she has
lots of experience but they didn't know
that right so I I I think um yeah and
what wait what was can you back up I'm
sorry the original question to was um so
we would see this bill as um you know
two two reasons right for for the
protection of the child and also for
training purposes so so that incident
could be reviewed and make sure that you
know proper procedure was followed and
if there was uh you know if there was
room to have prevented a further
escalation yes and in in my experience
again to what I I see is um I I see so
picture any one of you all of a sudden
was given a a student who was non-verbal
and all of a sudden started acting out
and you weren't sure how to do it what
we do is we go back to how we were
raised that you know that's that's kind
of how what was our discipline growing
up and and unfortunately a lot of what I
see is um ego that kind of gets in the
way like you're not going to tell me
what to do you're only 10 years old or
whatever I do you see a lot of that I
think when I taught at the at higher ed
what I really in um instructed my
teachers is really making sure to have
somebody feel safe that they made a
mistake and not reprimanded and say okay
how do we go back and look at that and
make sure that doesn't happen again
because it's hard it's not easy working
with somebody who who may be non-verbal
who has behavior and again and I always
say it it's not good versus bad it's
skills versus lack of but it I really
think more support needs to be caring
for the par professional so that they
can say I think I made a mistake uh you
of I'm sorry I have another question
it's not really a fellout but it's
related to okay thank you I forgot I
should have asked you this too um you
know um there was a mother that came
here and um it was very the I was very
um emotional about all of the testimony
on this day um and this one mother in
particular um talked about her son in
seclusion um for privacy purposes of the
child do you or not do you think that a
camera my thought would be to have a
camera outside of the seclusion room to
monitor who goes in and out because we
have limits of time
right where we where by law people need
to be you know going in and out um what
would your thought be on that e either
are you Pro or con a camera in the
seclusion room and or Pro or con a
camera outside of the seclusion room I
think the most important aspect to look
at that is what happened prior so that
you can learn and prevent it be
afterwards but typically what I have
seen is that there's a classroom with a
seclusion room in it and I think what
you just said I don't think it needs to
be inside of it I think kind of seeing
what what happened in the beginning and
like in that instance that went on way
too long before you even got in there
right so there were so many different
pivotal points that you could have
turned it around you're
welcome other
questions representative disimon thank
you
um thank you Mr chairman um I've been
thinking a lot of about this because
like representative Nelson and I'm not
speaking for the rest of the committee
but I my thought is that we were all
very concerned after all of that
testimony
um my thought is the protection of the
child
first um and the training and the
protection of the adult involved in the
incident as well so my thought is rather
than having surveillance cameras what
are your thoughts about about having a
body Cam that the adult in the situation
could use it like a panic button when
the
incident originates in the classroom
before we get to
seclusion the recording begins all the
way up to and including seclusion what
are your thoughts about that um I think
I think that might be a good idea I
don't know if anybody's ever done it I I
think the biggest thing about that and
again I don't see this in the in the
classroom I see this they're moved away
um into a and that's the thing is
they're moved away into a place where
nobody else is you I can guarantee you
you will not find a restraint in the
lunchroom in the front office you you're
not going to find it um and if you do
it's very very rare um it that might be
something that you know all of a sudden
but I think that again you want to get
it right when it's way beginning so that
again you can prevent it from happening
again but that could be a really good
idea representative Gibbons thank you Mr
chairman um just for my knowledge
purposes what how are they seclude or
sorry how are they restraining the
children because there's like an
infinite amount of ways to restrain
somebody so um I work in a hospital and
so we have like various methods um the
least restrictive would be like like a
vest or something um whereas the like a
little bit more restrictive would be
risk restraints but they're soft so
they're not going to cause like injury
if they're used properly um up to like
if someone's really being violent then
then there can be like leather
restraints so but that's Hospital based
I don't know what school-based is so
School based is usually hand it's
Hands-On um so it's you know it's not
MediCal it's not um you know any type of
drug or anything like that and I've
never seen any equipment you it's
Hands-On and it's um
typically so I have seen um again and
this is the most scariest one in the
prone prone and when you're not supposed
to do prone but I have seen it um so
prone is you know face down holding them
down and then I don't forget my daughter
knows them all um there's a basket hold
in all of these but um the ones where
you're really being held down and if you
think so you know just a little this is
what happens to our brains in our brains
we have an amydala that goes off and
says fight a flight we could all go into
fight a flight if we were walking down
the street in Boston and somebody came
after us that's what we would do and
there's a being sometimes set off
quickly and it takes about 20 minutes
but what happens is if you're now
holding down this person you're now
increasing the length of the um of the
of the escalation because they
continuing to be in fight or flight um
so there I would
say I I would say you know underneath
the arms and and um being held down but
typically than being brought into a
seclusion room to sit there and try to
deescalate yourself and it and you know
it's such a catch 22 all right you don't
want anything in the room that they
could hurt themselves in but then again
you put them in a padded room with the
door and and people will tell you that
they don't lock the door I'm going to
tell you I had one principal say this is
what we do and this is in the last year
and he put his foot up against the door
there's no lock there but this is what I
do I put the foot I put my foot against
the door so the child can't come out and
those are the things that we want to see
you know because um and then the the
adults are going into fight or flight
too when this happens like we go oh my
goodness there's something horrible
going on right so again it and there's
tends to be everybody has patterns of
behavior so it tends to be so a kid
might go I hate this or this is stupid
and that begins this whole chain of
events that if not dealt with over here
it tends to go all the way down there
and honestly for children it becomes
comfortable and I did have one student
who was restrained over 300 times in one
year who would walk off the bus and try
to get himself restrained so be done so
we could just get it out and know that
okay and then move on from the day so in
other words the the injuries are are
from hands and stuff so they're usually
like on the forearms y or trying to get
trying to get away and then they fall
and they bump their head because they're
trying to get away because if anybody's
holding you down you're trying to get
away right and then and people will say
well you know they weren't they weren't
staying still um well they're not going
to they're they're you know Young And
they're they're feeling that they're
going to be held and and they know after
the first time they know what's
happening they know the routine okay
thank you you're
welcome any other questions for Miss
Tracy yeah chairman long thank you Mr
chairman so of the uh IEP
students are there restraints or
seclusions for somebody who's not in I I
uh I typically only see that maybe if
somebody has like a 504 um um you you
don't I I have not experienced a typical
student getting restraint or or
seclusion have not experienced that um
if that does that usually triggers to
start doing an evaluation for what we
call invisible disabilities right and
those tend to not to come out actually
sometimes until we get to school so here
you are a parent thinking everything's
okay and then you bring them into school
and then they're not responding in the
environment so that's what I typically
say I have never in my life looking at
data or information or observed a
typical student being restrained or
secluded right so us this committee's
concentrating on IEP wouldn't wouldn't
be a disservice that that that should be
what we're yeah I don't think yeah and
again in in this language here it says
that that to put it in an IEP any parent
can have that already put in an IEP but
this is the problem that most parents
aren't educated and I'll tell you
parents are embarrassed who wants to
tell anybody that their kids having a
behavior problem and needed to be held
down or restrained at school they're not
telling people that and and um so then
they just sit there and especially the
lower so socio economics you know that's
they're embarrassed and ashamed of it
and they're trying to you know they may
even go home and now they're getting in
trouble again because of what happened
okay thank you very much Miss Trace we
do appreciate it thank you thank you for
telling me is there anyone else who
would like to come forward and just add
some insights uh to this uh
issue okay seeing none I'll uh entertain
uh discussion among committee members I
know two members in particular who have
some things that they do want to share
um representative Damon you had some
thoughts you wanted to share
specifically regarding body cameras and
we had our researcher go out and do some
research in that
regard yes thank you Mr chair um we uh
you
did um I did ask you and you did comply
with uh asking our researcher to get the
information that we all have on body
surveillance
cameras in
schools where the incidences may
happen
like all incidences where kids have to
be restrains restrained don't always
happen in the classroom they might
happen in the locker room they might
happen in the bathroom and if you're
having surveillance cameras in there
you're going to be seeing things
that no nobody really should
see so again it's my concern that other
students who are going to school able to
get through their academic
Day end the school day and go home are
going to be on these surveillance
cameras and their
privacy is infringed
upon on the other hand the kids who go
go to school and are not able to do that
because of whatever the reason are and
for every kid that can't get through the
school day you have a different reason
why they can't get through the school
day those kids need to be
protected in so far
as being able to report
to the
Educators the parents and more
importantly their doctors
why what caused this kid to act out what
did the teacher or whomever else it was
in the school um what did they do to
help deescalate this child in and things
of that sort and what works and what
doesn't work it's all inclusive I
believe
in in educating that child and how that
child needs needs to be educated and I
think that a panic button in and of
itself is only going to bring a myriad
of people into the situation
which can escalate the situation not
deescalate the situation but a body cam
on a particular teacher that is used
like a panic button
oh this child is getting tense acting
out boom push the panic button let's see
what we did right let's see what we did
wrong it's helping the child and it can
be used as a teaching tool for all
other Professionals in in the business I
hate having cameras and invading
anybody's privacy but I think in this
case it could help in that
respect representative Gibbons I think
has a question or a comment thank you um
yes just piggybacking off of what
representative D Simone said I
understand where you're coming from um
my concern would be the people that
don't want to push the body camera on uh
body camera like turn it on be for
whatever reason because
they I don't want to I don't want to
word it as want to be violent but they
they don't want their
actions seen because they don't want
reprimand or um or the situation might
be so highly escalated that they might
just innocently forget to turn it on so
I just I foresee problems if it manually
has to be turned on but I do see where
you're going where you don't necessarily
want to put
up um like cameras in bathrooms but you
might end up having a situation in a
bathroom so in other words I think that
a better solution might be to have the
body camera but not always to rely on it
um and have like the cameras in the room
that are kind of always
surveilling so that they really only
have to push the button if they're in
like a predicament like in a bathroom or
something like that and that there might
be consequences for the staff member if
they don't turn it on when they should
have um but that even that gets hairy
because like like what I was just saying
if the if the situation is that highly
escalated they might just instantly
forget to turn it on so to me it's a
catch 22 um where I just don't know what
the best solution is but I but I do see
it representative Nelson thank you Mr
chair um
I agree with both of you
and I just have um another um spin on on
recording so I did some research and I
shared with you guys yesterday um there
are three states who do have laws um
regarding videoing and they're all
specific to the use of cameras in in
special education settings in the
special education rooms only um and I
think that they all are not mandatory so
it would be they you know
May or could be wrong um on that part
but um we also had um some states um
Louisiana New Jersey Massachusetts New
York and Florida who who had bills and
they were not passed
um
and um I don't have that much
information on why they did not pass I
apologize about
that um so we do have some some um you
know prior statutes and other states
that we can kind of look at too thank
you for doing that
research representative Raymond I think
my concern is the expense I'm just
thinking about the expense of body
cameras I know like when NASA initially
got body cameras for our police force it
was
$350,000 a year and our police force is
uh orders of magnitude less than our
staff at school um like 100 times less
than the number of people we would need
them for staff at school um so I just
cannot imagine in a place where we're
having difficulty finding and paying par
Educators um that school districts would
have the money to do something like this
um I'm actually not opposed to expanding
U video cameras uh we already have them
in classrooms and Hall in hallways not
not typically classrooms but hallways
cafeteras other you know um main areas
in many of the high schools across the
state um so I could see expanding them
to certain other areas um but I I worry
about the Practical parts of it the
money and to spend enormous expense
investing in these things maintaining
them and
then not to spend enormous amounts of
money on the training and the
Recruitment and the retention of people
who do have the develop the skills and
then maintain the skills to react more
appropriately I just feel like when we
have a limited pool of money you put the
pool of money into teaching the skills
not you know buying
cameras representative
long thank you Mr chairman uh so in my
mind there's no doubt that video and
audio would be the best
um
um however it's what will add video and
audio capture uh and it's putting the
teacher um you know there's there's
there's another thing they've got to
remember is not only do I got to deal
with this how am I going to deal with
this oh I got to turn this on you know
you know those are the liabilities that
that I question uh in I would think body
cams you could get a body Cam that
wouldn't have a wide range you know it
would have a you know it would have a
direct range where you're not getting
other kids or what have you um um so
that in my mind that would be the best
now with respect to these forms are they
District drafted or is it uh the
Hampshire uh so we took the technical
advisory from the State Department of
Education and um put it into our
computer system but I believe most of
the state has the same essential facts
that are being required the um the
Department of Education made the
technical advisory it just didn't come
out until March so school districts
haven't had a long time to um create
their own forms integrate it into their
technology and then get it out to
everybody um and does somebody review
those forms so I don't know what the
rule is everywhere um in nashaa our
policy that the school board passed
requires that um somebody like the
building level principal administrator
has to review them and that um that the
uh superintendent's office also has to
review them um because we
wanted I was very affected by some of
the testimony here um and I'm was very
um disheartened to see the number of
restraints and seclusions in some of the
schools um so we wanted to make sure
that there were multiple eyes looking at
these things um and that parents were
having multiple communication from the
school um about what was happening but
again we we started training the staff
I'm saying we I had nothing to do with
it they started training the staff um
over the summer for the you know the
back to school stuff but the school's
only been in session for five days The
Kindergartners just started yesterday um
I'm not aware yet of you know what what
seclusions have happened um the other
thing that that came out in our local
discussion about restraint and seclusion
is as the national board of ed really
wanted to dive into this topic um was
you know what constitutes a restraint
and seclusion and the interpretation of
our board was if a child is running away
on the playground right and they need to
be stopped so they don't run into
traffic that is a restraint in seclusion
because we it's not seclusion it's a
restraint we've stopped the child if you
have kids who are fighting in the
hallway at the high school and they are
separated by administrators that
qualifies as an incident of restraint
and seclusion and staff should be using
this form and informing all the parties
so we made our definition more broad
than what was presented here today so
and I'm also uh just to close I'm also
thinking that audio and
video um can be um you know if if it
happens to capture other students then
uh you know that could be somebody could
go over that and and and get rid of the
you know block off or what have you um
and as far as finances I'm not even
concerned about that what is and I in my
mind what is the best and then let
people in finance figure out if we got
that right representative Gibbons and
then representative Nelson thank you um
as far as the financial part uh we could
put into the bill like a stepup plan um
because you know the the financial
portion of it says it's
indeterminable um so once they realize
what like what the actual cost and do an
assessment is we could just put in there
that they have like X number of years to
to get it fully implemented and just do
what they can you know in the meantime
also they don't have to get the most
expensive cameras out there that you
know in this day and age there's like
you can shop on Amazon and there's
cameras that are extremely cheap that
work very well well um and assuming that
there's decent Wi-Fi you know you can
just connect it to the Wi-Fi and you
know I so in other words you just don't
they they there are ways to minimize the
costs and if they if we did a step up
plan to it then um then that might work
that might be a solution also just want
to go back to um Point number two uh the
part in italics uh it says prior to the
use of and immediately after we could
change that to or knowing that sometimes
it might be impossible to notify them
prior to you know in in the best case
solution like like what the testimony we
just heard where the the kindergartener
just didn't want to put their hands in
the paint um and was getting like
escalated because of that you know sure
they they would have the time to contact
the parent prior to but if it's a fight
in the hallway they're not going to
necessarily have time to you know so so
we can be realistic about this and
and just change that to
or because prior to is sometimes
impossible representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman um in the
Texas law um it provides that the
cameras may be funded through the
solicitation or acceptance of gifts
grants and donations
ations and that um you know that might
be something that could be considered as
well um to defay the
cost and and representative long
actually it's another subject oh okay
just in that regard I mean I do agree
with representative long that our
concern is not finances we're all about
policy and then finances got to deal
with it but I am concerned about
unfunded mandates on the local level
because every school district is
different and some are really struggling
with finances and others are not so any
kind of financing that comes down in my
view needs to come from the state or
through through grants but that's just
my two cents no pun intended regarding
long chairman the the
um so what I'm what I'm thinking here is
that the the
IEP would have a plan that would allow
you so there could somebody in the IEP
that would say no I don't want my child
recorded at any time correct so this
would be only for people who said yes
that would that would work okay so so I
you know I don't
know what those percentages are I you
know I don't know how many parents would
say at no at no uh moment do I want my
child um recorded or audio um okay so so
it's not it may not as be as bad as what
we're thinking you know it may be just a
few more kids
um you know again if we could just get
over
the you know what's the liability for a
power and not turning it on
or it happens to be tilted for some
reason and I'm filming her instead of
him right you know I mean um you know
those are the only things that I I would
like to see a protection there um you
know and then you're GNA get somebody
who's
saying I've had it up to here I'm not
turning this on because I'm not going to
do some good things you know what I mean
you know and that's you know how how how
do you figure
that representative Nelson thank you um
I I I'm feeling the same way as
representa of long I like the idea of
body cams but for those Reasons I'm
thinking um you know the the cameras in
the special ed classroom only
um might
be something to think about too um I do
know that um we have um a lot of push
back about cameras in classrooms because
of um concerns of private and privacy in
the workplace for the teachers concerns
about privacy um of parents for their
children um but we do have um these
three states that have made it work so
in this only in the special education
rooms okay any other thoughts to
share all right seeing none the question
now is how do we go forward so needless
to say the uh H uh uh HB 1269 expired
when the session by it so it's for us to
decide whether or not we want to fire
legislation any one of us can fire
legislation representatives of a similar
mindset might decide that they want to
sit down and coordinate and draw up
something that ultimately can be
presented again listening to discussion
it sounds like we have all different
ideas and concerns and we're not really
at a a place where we have a consensus
we're talking a little bit maybe cameras
definitely there needs to be some more
uh teacher training um funding is a
question not necessarily for us because
that's not our priew so um is there
anyone who uh wishes to take the lead in
terms of um maybe drafting
something or do you wish to come back
and have further discussion so I'm open
to uh anything because this is this is
challenging no doubt yeah so so I if I
could uh thank you Mr chairman um I mean
can can we take a discussion uh could we
take a consensus on camera use I mean I
I you know I mean there's a lot of um
scenarios that would go with my approval
of that um but you know I mean I'm
thinking of being a parent and not
knowing why my kid has a
Shiner you know and and and you know the
parent tells me I'm not sure how that
happened you know and it could be
legitimate
um so audio and video is the best way we
have audio and video today you know it's
it's it's not
Antiquated um like you said there are
small videos and you know we could zoom
in on the child and the
par um so I I you know uh so I don't
know where we'd go
on a greant with speculation you know
with contingencies on using uh camera
and audio for the par
um would we consider that would be the
question yeah what directions I'm
thinking of this bill and has it relates
to the parent from a parent I'm not
knowing what's going on I'm upset um and
and the best way to know is the show uh
because even if I tell I don't believe
you you know you get into that CIO you
know or if I look at the form is
everything on the form well I don't know
you know maybe they had to fill out six
um so yeah representative Gibbons I mean
I think we're all in agreement I people
can speak up if they're not but that in
general this is good it's just Minor
Details uh that we're trying to figure
out so I mean I do think we should
probably just revise those Minor Details
and and maybe submit it again for the
you know for the next for
um well my suggestion in that regard if
we were to do that i' I'd like us to
review whatever is put forth because
ultimately it's going to come before the
full committee so I'd like us to have a
a handle on anything that's put forth
before it comes to us formally when
we're in session that's just my thought
in that regard right so so can can we do
a
report uh has to um you know we agree
that this should be brought forward and
further
legislation uh couple of the discussions
were the cameras contingent
upon you know the focus on the child and
the parent not the child sitting next to
him or whatever uh same with same with
audio
um uh I mean you know in my mind fixing
the parent
knowing seeing is going to give them the
best Comfort this is yeah you know maybe
you'll see something that happened that
wasn't written down we didn't see it you
know representative Raymond so I just I
still am
not comfortable with idea of putting
body cameras on teachers I'm just not I
mean I think we have discussions at this
at you know the state level about
whether or not we should arm teachers
and now we have discussions about body
camera teachers and I just feel like we
might as well just have police officers
do it since we're going to also have
discussions about what books teachers
can teach like at some point we have
to we have to let professionals be
professional having said that I'm not
opposed to having recordings of
incidents and I think child protection
is important and I think it's Paramount
um there is in law already under the
criminal statutes for wire tapping a
whole section about how audio and video
recordings are supposed to happen on
school buses and how that gets approved
by the school like it has to go through
the school board um and how uh who's
allowed to access it and how long it can
be you know retained and I think that if
we're going to talk about adding a audio
and video recording elsewhere like we
really ought to start looking at some of
those statutes as opposed to trying to
create something new out of you know
cobbling stuff together yeah so yes yeah
yeah we're not we're not looking at uh
we're not we're not looking at something
new we're not even going to put in the
language that some legislative may put
in we we're just given what our
discussions were um
my understanding is this is in special
ed classrooms
only um so so we're not having all
teachers wear body cams um it's it's
it's just suited for this uh and it's
specific to children that can't
communicate so I don't know if if I was
to bring legislator forward I would
exemp
um children that can communicate you
know I you know so so I mean
um you know the bottom line to me is how
do I assure a parent that they
know everything that happened the best
way is showing just uh um a bit
regarding uh what the comment you made
the uh bill as presented does not
specify special ed classrooms but
students who have IEPs and they're
mainstreamed and so this legislation
would imply that cameras would be
everywhere so when we go forth if we are
to talk about surveillance I'm hearing
from you that it would be specific to
classrooms representative Nelson I agree
with um representative Long's concerns
and I I have to say just personal
experience um both of my biological
children unfortunately have inherited
the clumsy Gene for me and um they've
come home with with bumps on the head
and fat lip um and it's just cuz they're
clumsy and they you know leaned over and
hit their face on the desk or whatever
but the report that you get from the
school nurse or the teacher whomever um
calls me at home can
be um cooperated by the child right so
you know hey I got a phone call from the
nurse today what
happened matching up and it's the same
thing right but these kids cannot do
that and um that is um a huge concern
too any other thoughts of
discussion okay so so hearing none
um do I take it representative long that
you might be inclined to draft something
I don't want to put that on you but just
and other like-minded individuals
you know we're not going to put in
language that we would do if we were
putting in legislation because we would
look at what representative uh
umay Raymond uh you know look at the
other statutes and then it may not come
to Children of family it may go to
education right you know um but yeah
just
just note what we discussed and and what
we were made aware of and what we would
recommend and then let them take it from
there okay so representative thison
actually made a motion that uh
representative long draw up a report
vote on that and we don't have to vote
on that just uh uh representative
dione's microphone was off so I just
wanted to make that clear for the
record and uh so that's that's good to
know so that's where we're going to go
uh forward and um when do we anticipate
maybe this would be done and we should
reconvene another meeting do we want to
set a date now for that or just wait
till you get back and we can formally
announce that later what's today
Wednesday so by by next next week okay
and then actually if you give me a date
if you give me a date when we're going
to
meet that'll tell you when I'm going to
write this up all right all right well
let's let's do that let's just take a
look at our calendars and we'll get back
to each other very very quickly and and
we'll let representative long know
and then we can we can schedule we can
schedule another another time to meet so
it'll only be a review of the
recommendation yes representative uh uh
Gibbons I just want to repeat that I
think it's important for the prior use
of comma and immediately after to be
changed to or as part of the
recommendation um I know that that's a
minor detail but I think it's
significant and and uh what do you guys
think of I I have issues with uh you
know asum as practical that that leaves
the door open for yeah so not they could
say they could specify uh how many hours
that I mean in
the in the um Hospital like if we were
had to put someone in restraints we have
like a certain amount of time before we
have to let the doctor know and get an
order so it is possible that they could
say like you have one hour to notify the
family after um someone had to be
restrained so you know and and that
would come back to a staff training
issue where they would have to be
notified that that's the new uh policy
so okay wonderful so before we adjourn I
do want to uh remind everyone that on
Monday September 23rd uh The Joint
Office of the child advocate in Waypoint
um is going to have a documentary SC
screening of the kids we lose and I
think everyone did receive this card
there was also a mailing as well as an
email so I'll be in attendance uh
followed by a um panel discussion with
Dr Ross green and um the documentary
it's award-winning documentary and it
deals with the topic that we are
currently grappling with so I think
that's important for us to take a look
at that might uh assist us as we move
forward and we all know that we can file
legislation in November so we still have
plenty of time uh moving forward so with
that if I hear no other questions or
comments or thoughts I guess we'll
adjourn and I wait to hear an email of a
definitive time when we'll meet again
okay all right how's that sound
everybody all right well thank you very
much thank you so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna um type these up on the
computer okay and I'll send them
to our committee researcher right
all right Karen